I don't know if you saw the last time
rebel was on but the last time rebel
displayed her rapping skills alright
don't worry we're not gonna make you do
it again they're very good get forever
it was no actual proper use a rapper I'm
actually also good at rapping kebabs
though I feel a bit sick but we've now
learned ladies and gentlemen that rebel
Wilson you are sort of trained sort of
ninja yeah
have I been in a novice all-star martial
arts championship yes did I get my face
punched in yes because we've got is it
called the nunchucks nunchucks yeah
that's the official Asian name there so
that I ought to say but my god song cuz
in this country nunchucks apparently are
illegal unless you have some sort of
qualification which rebel has and also
these ones aren't these order these ones
aren't the really dangerous ones these
are just I don't know where we got them
from here toy shop yes oh don't mess
around with your nunchucks okay so you
can do a little lunch up to splasher
way not need maths but no guarantees
just want to go like this
during the stunt routine
to protect your side I go over here and
I've moved down a bit uh okay so wait
till not me cause it would really help
us if you didn't hurt anyone
during this okay people in the front row
maybe just protect your money-making if
you want some music for this yeah I mean
you need music to do now
Oh
I put them away
that was what for yeah so if you think
you've mugging me on the street maybe
think again
all you want is a dinkle but you envy is
a schwag a sings will you they
cool cut as up why that was asked it was
going when he won I look behind me and
there's a bus goes past with my face on
it